6 24 on your Wednesday morning with an
estimated 100
000 plus cars on Las Vegas highways at
any given time sure we're going to spend
a lot of time talking about that but
that does not mean we shouldn't talk
about the 800 plus buses and Paratransit
vehicles that serve the valley
especially as weeks if not months of
triple digit temps are going to be here
even if they're not here just yet
the regional transportation commission's
out with its annual heat safety campaign
this year called Summers coming in hot
it includes the always Rock Solid cool
advice know the weather wear lightweight
light-colored clothes limit time
Outdoors lots of water those really
apply to all of us but there's some
stuff especially for RTC Riders like
digital discounts and other deals and
weekly water giveaways and they're
giving away sunscreen and other helpful
goodies we have the dates times and
locations in the online version of this
story on our website 8newsnow.com just
click traffic then drive any crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone you can join the drive
any crazy conversation at traffic 8 at
8newsnow.com